weltweit wird an fünftel der energie für
licht gebraucht bei uns sind das
meistens led lampen die sehr viel licht
und das mit wenig strom produzieren doch
uns kommen mittlerweile immer mehr
studien auf den tisch die led licht als
große gefahr für unsere augen
identifizieren und genau deswegen sag
ihr auch auf das thema bei whatsapp
gekommen und habt es euch gewünscht
daher ist es was also genau das problem
an led lampen ist und wie wir das risiko
für unsere gesundheit senken können das
jetzt bei kik zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpassen sie nichts herzlich
willkommen dank eurer augen könnt ihr
mich und dieses video hier jetzt sehen
die augen sind tatsächlich unser
zentrales sinnesorgan bis zu 80 prozent
aller infos aus der umwelt nehmen wir
dank ihnen war unsere augen haben also
jede menge zu tun permanent gucken wir
auf laptops smartphones oder fernseher
und genau das könnte ziemlich
unangenehme folgen für uns haben denn
zur hintergrundbeleuchtung in tablets
und so weiter sind meistens leuchtdioden
also leds eingebaut sie verbrauchen
deutlich weniger energie als klassische
glühbirnen und werden so mittlerweile
nicht nur in bildschirm sondern auch in
lampen scheinwerfern und werbeplakaten
also werbedisplays eingesetzt konkret
produzieren die led-lampen blaues und
gelbes licht um am ende das gewünschte
weiße licht zu erhalten doch
mittlerweile mehren sich die anzeichen
dass das enthaltene blaue liegt sehr
schädlich für unsere augen sein könnte
im gegensatz zum spektrum des
sonnenlichts das gleichmäßig über den
gesamten wellenlängenbereich des lichts
verteiltes zeigt das spektrum von led
eine spitze bei 400 bis 480 nanometern
dieses licht ist besonders energiereich
und kommt fast ungefiltert durch das
auge auf die netzhaut denn anders als
das uv licht wird es nicht im vorderen
augenbereich absorbiert so soll es
starke schäden an netzhaut und sehzellen
hervorrufen konkret entsteht ein foto
oxidativer stress sauerstoffradikale
entstehen die proteine und lipide
schädigen und dann zum tod der sehzellen
führen können und das ist irreversibel
abgestorbene zellen werden nicht mehr
ersetzt und das sehvermögen nimmt stück
für stück ab zudem schädigt led-licht
wohl auch die pigmentzellen der netzhaut
alterungsprozesse werden beschleunigt
vermehrt abfallstoffe gebündelt und
genau das schädigt dann wiederum die
sehzellen wieviel blaues licht notwendig
ist um diesen worst case schaden zu
verursachen wissen forschungsteams
allerdings noch nicht ganz genau
hinweise dazu liefert allerdings jetzt
eine studie aus frankreich
hierbei wurde untersucht welche
auswirkungen die verschiedenen licht
arten auf unsere augen haben können das
ganze wurde an ratten getestet von denen
jeweils eine gruppe licht aus
leuchtröhren herkömmlichen glühbirnen
und led licht ausgesetzt wurde also drei
gruppen alle lichtquellen führten bei
einer hohen intensität von 6.000 lux zu
entzündungen die am ende zum absterben
der sehzellen führten bei 500 lux also
einer deutlich geringeren
lichtintensität dagegen wurde die
netzhaut der tiere nur durch das
led-licht beeinträchtigt das alles sind
die ergebnisse aus tierversuchen
langzeitversuche an menschen die gibt's
noch nicht außer natürlich jetzt hier
mit den lampen die wir sie benutzen und
bildschirmen doch auch schon derzeit
kommen einige faktoren zusammen mehr
leds werden in den verschiedenen
bereichen des lebens eingesetzt und wir
nutzen sie intensiver als früher
dazu kommt die besondere spektrale licht
zusammensetzung für die unsere augen
besonders anfällig sind nicht zuletzt
wird die lichtintensität von led lampen
durch eine eu norm geregelt und es gibt
einige aspekte die jeder selbst beachten
kann um das risiko von augenschäden zu
senken gefährlicher als das wahlweise
led licht ist das kalt weise licht zudem
kann man das licht von monitoren in
einen gelblichen bereich umstellen und
so seine augen schon unbedingt vermeiden
sollte man es direkt in helle led
quellen hineinzuschauen beispielsweise
kann man beim fernsehgucken lieber noch
eine weitere lichtquelle im raum dazu
einschalten und wie man nicht
manipulieren kann das erklärt hier
doktor watson und das ist wirklich
unglaublich was da so alles möglich ist
also da draufklicken unbedingt
abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran
hier gibt es übrigens noch den link zu
seinem kanal
[Musik]